[Music]
so hello everyone my name is Yael togusa
I'm from Amsterdam and today I'm going
to tell you about a Kegel I participated
in last Christmas this is a different
kettle than the usual Kegel because it's
actually an optimization problem which
involves some data so a little bit about
myself
I studied computer science and
artificial intelligence in the
Netherlands after that I did a few
internships and then I became a data
scientist at codit a driven consultancy
composite company based in Amsterdam in
data science and engineering were hiring
finally I participated with my colleague
Vincent VAR madam who's speaking next
doors at this moment so the problem I
just told you it's an optimization
problem and the thing is that Santa has
to deliver presents but he lost the list
of which toys should go in which back so
now he's trying to find out how to fill
a thousand back with toys and for this
he needs to maximize weight he wants to
take back as much weight as possible but
he can't pack too much weight in one bag
because then I wrote there at 50
kilograms so for this Kegel you have 120
submissions which is important as well
turnout so far so good but one thing is
different than usual and that's the the
toy weights are unknown but fixed so if
the total weights are unknown what do we
have we have these distributions so for
example I have a horse and I know that
on average this horse weighs about six
kilograms and I so some of these look
quite normal but others don't of course
if you look at the coal or the gloves
once for example
so the toys that you are going to use
they were sampled from these
distributions so for example you get a
six thousand horses and each of these
were sampled from these distributions
but you don't know the weight of a
specific horse so horse 24 yeah so this
is basically what it looks like what you
got so if you have any background in
optimization I think you will probably
wonder is this a knapsack
so who for those who don't know the
knapsack problem it's an np-hard
optimization problem where you have to
put stuff in backs so of course that
sounds quite similar you know the
weights and you know the value of items
and you don't have to pack all of them
so in this case we have to pack multiple
backs so in that's why it's a multiple
knapsack and we can write down an
optimization problem with all the
constraints and all that but still one
thing is missing and that's the weights
because we don't know them so the first
thing we thought is can we estimate
these weights just by using the PDF of
the toys so for example you could take a
horse toy and you could say well I
expect this horse to be six kilograms on
average so I'll just use this in my
optimization problem for solving this we
use the Google or our tools so it's a
unified unified interface to a set of
solvers so it has boolean satisfiability
it has Traveling Salesman problems and
also IOPS so the one we use here you can
construct your problem in Python it's
quite nice so you say ok I have this
objective I have these constraints and I
need a solver and go it's really as easy
as this so you can add them with a loop
and it's really well once you've written
down the math of the optimization
problem it's quite easy
so this is what we did but it turned out
that it didn't really work and it didn't
really work because a lot of these bags
will there if you look for example at
these gloves you will see that they come
in two variants basically so you have a
light one which is about one kilograms
and you have a heavier one which is
three to four kilograms now if I take
the expected value of this gloves toy I
will get somewhere in the middle so for
half these cloths I will sort of over
eight underrate the weight that they
have so when I start packing then often
these bags with gloves will tear and
that's why this doesn't work in practice
now there are multiple things you can do
to resolve this the first would be to
actually relax your problem so if this
is your optimization targets you can say
okay I don't or I mean if this is your
constraint that says you need fifty
kilograms max in it in a bag you could
say well let's not try to pack 50 but
let's try to pack a little bit less to
see if this will cause fewer back sit
there and this is the case and you can
play around with this but it's still a
bit wacky and it doesn't really work out
in the end because it's still mismatch
between the weights that you give in and
actual ways now there's also a different
solution and it's a different solution
involves looking at entire bags instead
of specific toys so the decision that my
optimizer will make is now well I use
this specific bag which is for example
two horses and a book or will instead of
using saying should this specific horse
go in this bag so you make it a
different problem
so for this we would need the back
weights which we don't have of course
but we do know we do have the waist the
probability distributions for the
specific toys so what Finn certain I did
we said okay of all the combinations of
toys you can make let's try all the
combinations of toys up to 11 toys I
mean at some point you can't do this
anymore because there are too many
combinations and just let's just start
sampling from the toys and see what
comes out in terms of the weight of this
bag so on the left here you see the
weight distributions for example for a
bag which contains one bike and two free
trains and on the right you see the
utility so that's the actual score that
I expect to gain from this bag which is
different because of course if it's
heavier than 50 kilograms about there so
you see that we clip there and then
there's suddenly a huge spike at zero so
this we did for all possible bags up to
the 11th power and then you see this so
if you would map out of all these
possible bags the expected value the
expected utility so what you expect to
gain from it first is the fill
probability like how often did this bag
actually tear in my sampling in my
simulation you'll see that there are
different kind of bags so some of these
are low risk and high value so these are
the ones you see in the in the left
corner so those are the bags that are
sort of always around the same weight
then there are some bags that are
actually have a higher fill probability
so those are the bags that are closer to
50 but they'll feel more often and now
the question is which of these types of
bags should you use in your optimization
so we tried around a bit with this
so here the the red line is expected
less in the expected value by computing
with the ILP and the blue dots are the
actual failures that we got when we
would simulate this with different kind
of gift permutations so what you see is
at the horizontal axis if we take more
risk and we increase the maxvill
probability that we allow in our backs
we see that at some point the results
start to level off and you don't get any
more score but that's on average of
course because there we simulate over a
thousand shuffles maybe but what you
might want to do so for example here we
said okay we looked at where they are
the actual highest results on average so
that's maybe around 0.4 fail probability
and we pick this solution and of course
you have 120 submissions so you can
actually permute the like know you know
if you instead of baby horse 6-4 this
back I can also big horse seven it will
make a difference in this quarter that I
get back so again just try a lot of
times so one person on the on the forums
actually Friday's in a simulation so the
the blue distribution that you see here
are the sort of the resulting scores
that he got back and the green
distribution is if he would submit 60
times the same solution structure the
best course that he would get you'll see
that actually the like the best score in
sixty tries is of course better than the
the average score but he also concluded
that this solution isn't really a very
viable to to get a high score so then we
thought would it be possible to use some
of our submissions to learn something
about the test set and this is actually
where the competition got interesting so
for this we used by MC it's
probabilistic programming framework for
Bayesian modeling so you can set up
graphical models and
all kinds of posterior distributions for
example you can ask questions like if I
know that I have a 70 70 percent chance
of getting the flu weather now the
probabilities or whether the
distribution look like for me to get
muscle pain or congestion other
questions you can ask also are the other
way around so you can say okay if I if I
have if I actually noticed that I have
muscle pain as as an observation what is
now the probability distribution for
getting flu and we could also do this
for this problem where we say okay I
have a few toys for example two horses
in a ball and I'm going to combine those
and put them in one submission so we'd
submit only a few backs with only a few
items and we'd say okay what's the score
we get back we did we do that multiple
times with sort of overlapping for
example horse two goes in multiple
submissions else you can learn of course
so if you want to do this in PI MC it's
actually quite easy so at the top you
see we define these weights and then we
say okay these random burials what sort
of distribution do they have so here we
say normals but they would actually the
the specific toy distribution but this
was a trial to see if this has any value
at all or if it's possible yes then you
say okay I had a few observations so
here we say we have three different
submissions of combinations and then we
start tracing or sampling and you can
actually see the sort of bar at the
bottom because it's sampling so you know
when it's we will be done because it's a
set sample size so what do we get back
on the left here we see the posterior
distribution so what the sampler came up
with you see multiple lines because
these were the difference we did it in
parallel on different course and it's
interesting to see that for the like two
of the weights or two of the toys all
the different treads came to the same
conclusion so the bottom ones on the
left but for the other ones they
actually found multiple solutions and
that's because if you look at the system
of equations there are actually multiple
solutions so for example one solution is
that new two would be four new one would
be a weight of two but you can also turn
this around or you can say one is five
and the other ways one and actually
multiple solutions are found on the
right we see the trace plot so that's
sort of how the sampler progressed and
we find that it actually converges at
some point so then we try to wrap this
up a little bit so we said okay now we
have multiple toys and we have fewer
equations basically can we still do it
can we with larger bags of toys can we
still learn and basically the answer is
that it's complicated we see that the
sampler didn't really converge so there
wasn't much learning going on there and
that's basically where we quit our
participation in the competition however
when you look at the leaderboard and
this is a distribution of the public
leaderboard over time so the big spike
is a public's mission a lot of people
will also submit of course we will see
that at the front a few people just keep
steadily progressing and they kept
getting better and better and better so
you start wondering what if they've been
you've been doing
so I already said that I can submit the
same solution multiple times and I can
permute the the IDS of the gift so
instead of for seven years or six and
this will probably like to gain me a
little bit now you could also do this in
a sort of binary search way where you
say okay I split my solution and now I
submit half of it so five hundred bags
and then I say okay it's this score that
I get back is it below or above average
and if it's above average I want to keep
it but if it's below average then I want
to preview it a bit and this way it's
you actually get a lot more results than
just permuting everything all the time
the second approach there are read on
the forums is called coal mining so
basically one of the toys has this
peculiar distribution where it's either
very like either has a very low weight
or it actually has a really high weight
but really as high as almost 50 so this
will be a back in itself so then one guy
like early on realized that if he would
mine enough of these goals and you know
their exact weights could actually
assemble like a good bags one at a time
so we started doing that but skort is a
bit slow and you only have 120
submissions and then he came up with
this and it's actually quite a clever
trick that a lot of people copied later
on because he shared it mean well
basically how it works is I have a few
bags and now I'm wondering it's one of
these like over weight is it going to
bust so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to submit it and I'll get back a
score and you see if you look at the top
table that one of these bags actually is
overweight and so I can immediately see
okay it's overweight now I will have a
few items like lightweight items for
example gloves that I already know the
specific weight of and I will add to
each of these bags one of these small
items and then I will say because like
maybe I should mention that what you're
actually trying to find out of course
you can see
the score is 95 so one of them bust but
you don't know which one it is so that's
the thing you're trying to find out now
so you add these small lightweight items
they say okay what's my score now and
then you can just look at the which of
the linear combinations will actually of
course you have to make sure these extra
weight items these small items are oh I
have a different weight and now you can
see okay I know the difference between
the score before and after I know which
of these two extra items actually moved
on and I can see said okay apparently
back three was the bust one and now I'm
doing it only with three bags but if you
can if you have multiple of these
lightweight items you can really scale
it up so some people do this with 20
different bags at a time and if you only
have to fill a thousand they have a
hundred and twenty submissions you can
actually get quite far now of course you
can do all this efforts and solve I'll
piece and try to really learn from your
extra submissions or you can actually
take a look at the random number
generators that produce these items and
actually try to enumerate those and one
guy did this and at the end he turned
out that he had actually correct the
seat so you could completely show the
entire item weights so that's also a
solution okay thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much anybody questions
and thank you for the presentation I'm
wondering if there is some kind of real
problem where you can use this solution
to this learning optimization problem
yeah well I think in that case you're
basically looking for real-life multiple
knapsacks of which there are definitely
examples I don't have one with me at the
moment but if you type this in your
Google you will find a few I think thank
you very much
[Applause]
you